got quite a bit to show you that you
haven't seen before walking onto the set
of the philosopher's stone was a dream
come true for daniel emma and rupert
hogwarts was basically their playground
the film itself might deal with some
serious issues like a two-faced
professor looking for the demise of one
of his students but for the most part
the behind the scenes was full of laughs
pranks and adorable on-set crushes
though there was one professor the
actors were petrified of
camera
ready to find out who my name is gary
i work for the rspca if hogwarts was
their playground the rest of the
children in the cast were the golden
trio's classmates which as you can
imagine led to a lot of onset chaos
it was near impossible to get them all
focused at the same time
director chris columbus says they were
constantly laughing and fooling around
in between takes and sometimes even
during takes
look how adorable they all were it might
have taken some extra effort from the
adults on set but on the bright side it
led to impeccable on-screen chemistry
the audition process for daniel emma and
rupert couldn't be any more different
for daniel it was just another day at
the theater with his parents when
producer david heyman who had already
had his eye on daniel for the role
convinced them to just come in for an
audition
sign up for the entire series and
it was all to be filmed in america but
daniel's parents weren't really up for
relocating their 11 year old son
luckily they ended up filming in the uk
and it all worked out emma attended a
drama class for her audition basically
um my school got an invitation after she
was hand selected from her classmates
she went on to audition eight more times
before she secured her spot
rupert's audition is probably the most
wild story we've heard so far he heard
about the open call auditions and sent
in a video of himself dressed as his
drama teacher while performing a rap
then i made my script thing up and sent
it off it may have landed him an
in-person audition but it didn't save
him from embarrassment
the golden trio had almost absolutely no
experience in film which led to a lot of
nervous actors on the first day of
filming i was
terrified not only were they acting but
they were learning the ins and outs of
memorizing lines and hitting their marks
not to mention all the professional
lingo they made so many mistakes that
director chris said he had to film with
multiple cameras each actor always had a
camera on them this was so they could
catch as much footage as possible and
piece it all together that's why the
first film is a little choppy they
couldn't get through a full scene
without someone making a mistake rupert
don't smile and emma don't put your head
on forward chris deserves all the awards
for how much effort he put into the film
he wasn't shy about how much he enjoyed
working with actors but he went the
extra level for the amateur actors on
set
a lot of the time he would be behind the
cameras acting the scene out alongside
daniel emma and rupert so they could
take reference from him look at him go i
always you know laughed and said we
should put a camera on chris we don't
have access to all the bloopers from the
set but we're willing to bet a lot of
them would include emma while filming
she had a habit of mouthing everyone
else's lines and ruining entire takes
we're sure they appreciated how focused
and eager she was but emma says the
whole process traumatized her i really
wanted to do my job well and i and i
kind of overdid it she of course
eventually worked through it
what would a movie set be without some
pranks for this franchise at least in
the early days daniel was a prankster
mastermind i'm an angel i'm an angel
sure you were dan he was so good he
managed to get a hold of robbie coltrane
also known as hagrid's phone and
reprogrammed it from english to turkish
genius besides that he was constantly
wandering set looking for ways to prank
people performing magic tricks and
overall being cheeky
normally calling cut on set means
everyone breaks character but a lot of
the time alan rickman who played snape
would remain in character between takes
which also meant dan and rupert were
terrified of him both on and off camera
i was constantly having to remind myself
that it was certainly a film
one time rupert drew a funny caricature
of alan rickman while filming rupert was
absolutely terrified when he realized
allen had noticed the drawing from over
his shoulder luckily this was one time
alan decided to break character i've
made him sign it and i have it in my
possession
alan took it home and said it was
something that was very dear to him our
hearts
it wouldn't be a set full of preteens
and teens without any crushes developing
we didn't know it at the time but emma
watson revealed years later that she had
a major crush on tom felton from the
ages of 10 to 12. we love a bad guy and
he was a few years older and he had a
skateboard and that just did it really
but tom would refer to her as a little
sister and she had her heart torn in two
a lot of people wondered why they wrote
out hermione's huge buck teeth in the
script well it was because emma watson
couldn't speak properly with them teeth
test
keith's test she did multiple camera
tests with them and even filmed one
scene with them that made it to the
final cut but ultimately it just didn't
work out
we all know the irony of people telling
harry you have your mother's eyes when
daniel indeed did not
instead of the green eyes harry has in
the novel daniel had blue eyes and it
wasn't for lack of effort daniel did try
and wear contacts but had a painful
allergic reaction that forced them to
film without them
you know the scene at the end of the
philosopher's stone where harry is
saying goodbye to hagrid his eyes were
only puffy because he'd been wearing
them does that count as method acting
the floating candles in the great hall
are iconic and they knew they had to get
them perfect at first they were using
real candles hung with fishing line but
those candles started melting and
falling on the actors below yikes that
meant they only had one or two takes to
get the grand entrance perfect
so the reaction you see from the first
years here is the actual reaction from
the kids it was the first time they had
seen that set no acting required
speaking of the great hall director
chris says that those were the most
difficult scenes to film that's because
they had to control over 300 children in
one space even the child actors
themselves don't know how he managed it
i don't know how he does it he used
various techniques to get everything
perfect but then re-blocking for another
take would take forever
let the feast
begin the great hall just seems to be
the place where everything went awry you
know that delicious looking food that
always lines the tables in the films
well for the first film that food was
very real and needed to last them
through three days of filming under the
heat of the set lights there was no way
that food was staying fresh which meant
the hall didn't smell very pleasant
the philosopher's stone is like 99
focused on just children which meant in
order to film the movie at the time they
had to petition for uk labour law
adjustments they managed to get the kids
on set for nine hours a day but only
about four to five of those hours were
filming the rest were dedicated to
school and breaks it's tough
um but we had brilliant kids and they
did really well
owls play a huge role in all of the
films and to take the movie realism to a
whole new level chris managed to use
real life trained owls it wasn't easy
but they managed to do it
miles
the magical scene where that i will
swoop in to deliver the students post
was shot by filming owls individually
and then editing them all together later
on owls are beautiful creatures but they
are difficult to train filming a harry
potter movie might sound like a magical
experience for a young actor and it was
but it was also a huge challenge after
the huge success of the first film the
cast and crew came back for the chamber
of secrets raring to go but when it came
to balancing schoolwork tons of cgi a
cast of hundreds and everything else
filming the second harry potter movie
was no easy feat we're taking a look at
some of the most amazing behind the
scenes moments from the chamber of
secrets
you might think that the young actors
and hard-working crew would have been
given a break between filming the first
harry potter film and the chamber of
secrets but nope they started shooting
the second movie only two days after the
first premiered and coming back to work
was like getting a big family back
together
after getting all of the introductions
out of the way in the first movie the
second time around allowed them to not
only make the chamber of secrets more
funny but also way darker and far more
action-packed the director chris
columbus was so excited to be able to
direct more of the action and daniel
radcliffe was definitely on board when
it came to making the audience laugh
while they mostly stuck to the script a
few key lines from the chamber of
secrets were actually improvised first
the hilarious moment when malfoy turns
to goyle or harry disguised as goyle and
says what the naked breed was made up by
tom felton because he forgot his line
and secondly when jason isaacs says
potter will always be around to save the
day
he came up with it on the spot luckily
daniel radcliffe was right there with
him as his response don't worry i will
be
was totally off the top of his head
according to daniel all of the flying
car sequences took around a month to
film which meant that he and rupert were
trapped together in a tiny car for four
weeks luckily he thought rupert was
hilarious and the two kept each other
laughing even after flying right into
the whomping willow oh yeah that was
really fun it's clear that they had a
great time because dan said those were
some of the best filming days i think
and they had only just begun
rupert and daniel weren't the only ones
who became fast friends because it turns
out that even though they might be
rivals on screen dan and tom felton who
plays malfoy actually get along really
well but we're not really enemies we
love each other really they had a lot of
fun filming their quidditch scenes
spending hours hanging from the ceiling
in front of a giant blue screen joking
around between takes
after the huge success of the first
movie they were able to spend a little
less time worrying and a lot more time
having fun on the set of the chamber of
secrets even doing things that seemed
like the complete opposite of a good
time for example the scene where ron has
to throw up a bunch of giant slugs might
be a nightmare to most of us but for
rupert it was a whole other story but it
tasted quite nice actually they even let
him choose the flavor
three new big characters were introduced
in the second movie lucious malfoy
gilderoy lockhart and of course dobby
but this movie was made before the days
of motion capture and super realistic
cgi so acting opposite dobby was
actually a big challenge for daniel
radcliffe challenging on the part of the
visual effects team and challenging on
the part of dan radcliffe dobby wouldn't
be created until after the movie was
filmed so he spent the entire time
acting opposite an orange ball
nowadays they might shoot the entirety
of hogwarts on a green screen but back
then they did almost all of it for real
one of the most complicated tasks was
building dumbledore's office which took
over
250 people to do for just that one room
along with building the space they had
to commission a handful of different
artists to paint all of the portraits
and paintings that hang on his walls
playing quidditch might look like an
amazing amount of fun but it turns out
it took quite a bit of getting used to
according to daniel radcliffe in the
first movie it was actually really
painful to spend so long up there
sitting on a tiny broomstick suspended
by wires but luckily by the time the
chamber of secrets came around they had
figured out a way for it to be a lot
less painful and way more fun by rigging
in more comfortable seats and foot rests
and using wires to keep their weight off
of the broom according to chris columbus
the main trio quickly went from actors
with no experience to seasoned
professionals from the first movie to
the second i've developed as a person so
much everybody on set has everything got
a little easier and started to flow more
the second time around and what once
took 10 to 15 takes to nail down only
took three or four on the chamber of
secrets
even though they may have been becoming
best friends that didn't mean that
daniel emma and rupert were free from
teasing each other every now and again
in fact they did it all the time why are
you so determined to embarrass me
because they were all growing at
different rates they were all racing to
keep up with one another especially emma
who was the only girl in the group but
don't worry rupert and daniel didn't
gang up on her and she could totally
hold her own i am taller video
or i will make myself
the young actors were really excited to
see their characters grow and change
from where they were in the first year
at hogwarts to the second daniel
radcliffe was intent on making harry
more grounded the second time around in
the first movie he was more just
reacting to things around him and in the
second he really started to take charge
of his world emma watson said that
hermione definitely relaxed a bit for
the second film hermione definitely
becomes more sort of easy going ron
stepped into the big brother role with
ginny now enrolled at hogwarts and also
with his new owl who as rupert grint put
it is he's really really
stupid and clumsy
one thing that everyone in the cast and
crew could agree upon is that chris
columbus was the absolute best director
for the job not only was he a great
leader he also knew exactly how to talk
to the young actors and get the best
work out of them he manages to get the
whole set completely psyched up while
some directors sit in another room
looking at the monitor and never
speaking to the cast chris did exactly
the opposite and was super hands on the
entire time
having already been working together as
a giant family for over a year on the
chamber of secrets the actors finally
started to feel like they could step out
of their comfort zones a little bit one
thing that the success of the first film
enabled us to do was to sit back and be
a little more relaxed for dan he was so
shy during the first movie that he would
never offer his opinion about anything
other than a funny prank or two but when
it came to the second one he was a lot
more comfortable and started sharing his
ideas and thoughts with the director and
really getting into the work in the
second i kind of have a bit more
confidence with putting ideas forward
according to emma watson one of the
biggest challenges of being a young
actor on a giant hollywood set is trying
to fit everything in because while most
kids their age would be in school full
time all of the school-age harry potter
actors had to be tutored on set during
the day while also filming the movie for
up to 12 hours a day
they would run from the set to the
tutoring trailer for a 15 minute lesson
back to hair and makeup and on set again
all day long after all this it seems
like making the chamber of secrets was
an amazing experience for everyone
involved and we're sure that none of the
crew would trade it even for a second we
enter completely our own world
the prisoner of azkaban is one of the
best harry potter movies but it's also
when things started getting serious on
set things were more lighthearted the
actors pulled pranks on each other and
emma watson had fun punching tom felton
even though it wasn't in the script how
did they pull off such a dark film and
turn it into a blast behind the scenes
let's find
this lumo scene at the beginning of the
third movie had some fans questioning
wizarding world rules wouldn't harry get
in trouble for using charms outside of
school but regardless filming the scene
was fun and a bit sweaty
i wouldn't touch that it's very wet
harry seems to be in his own private
cocoon but on set daniel had director
alfonso quran telling him what to do
under that blanket he was sitting on
this illuminated platform that had him
feeling a bit warm and technicians were
controlling the light from his wand
hermione punching draco will forever go
down in harry potter history as one of
the most satisfying moments of the
series but according to tom felton the
scene wasn't supposed to include a punch
at all actually originally said in the
script that hermione uh slaps draco the
punch idea came when both actors decided
they wanted to add a little intensity to
the scene apparently emma has a pretty
good punch and she enjoyed every minute
of it emma was looking forward for that
moment harry potter might be the chosen
one but even he's not above getting
pranked by his professors for this scene
in the great hall michael gambin and
alan rickman teamed up to put a fart
machine in daniel radcliffe's sleeping
bag so it would go off while filming not
even dumbledore could keep a straight
face
making harry invisible takes a lot of
cgi and a green cloak which can be a bit
hard to take seriously in this scene
they used string to get ron's hat and
hermione's hair to move but the actors
had trouble not cracking up when daniel
threw off his green cloak and popped in
just like three kids having a snow day
that was not funny the first person who
ever really made daniel feel starstruck
on set was gary oldman but isn't it
fitting that daniel looked up to the
actor playing his on-screen godfather
the two ended up developing a bond
similar to sirius and harry's daniel
also had this to say about movies three
and five which he thinks were his best
performances i think that is in part to
do the fact that i have gary open around
speaking of serious black sirius's
disheveled look for the movies included
wild hair a grungy beard and those
awesome nordic inspired tattoos even
though his body art was never mentioned
in the books alfonzo quran and gary
oldman decided to make the character
theirs i look like i've escaped from
prison don't you think
oldman came up with sirius's hairstyle
while kiran designed all the tattoos
himself as director alfonso quran came
up with a lot of the film's vision even
though he had never even read the series
before getting hired working with kids
definitely had his challenges he had a
swear jar to try and keep himself from
cursing in front of the young cast but
he still had a great time on set i was
always be going to him you know how
should i do it just tell me what to do
he'd go no you've got you've got to do
it yourself he helped get the young
actors where they needed to be
emotionally and he even let them
improvise some of their lines like in
this scene where he encourages emma to
follow her instincts if it helps keep it
the final design for the dementors was
also heavily influenced by koran the
crew tried a lot of different techniques
to get them right like having them on
strings then puppeteered in the water
before they finally settled on cgi i was
a little hesitant about cg so i wanted
to do everything old school it's the
slow movement extra long cloaks and
layers of fabric that end up making the
final result so perfect isn't he
say hello to buckbeat prisoner of
azkaban introduced us to care of magical
creatures and buckbeak but creating the
hippogriff behind the scenes was both
fun and challenging the animatronic
model really moves and was made of
hand-cut and painted feathers it took a
huge team four and a half months to
create three of them for filming check
out daniel riding this motion rig on set
so they could later finish the scene
with cgi
alfonso quran seems to be full of good
advice and always knows exactly what to
tell his actors to get a good
performance one tip he gave daniel was
to picture his celeb crush cameron diaz
in a bikini during scenes like this when
he needed to look shocked or taken aback
and it worked another fun fact is that
emma watson's crush was actually on set
with her she admitted she had a bit of a
thing for tom felton he was a few years
older and he had a skateboard
rupert grant loved feeling like a family
while filming the movies but he admits
it felt a little suffocating at times he
even compared it to groundhog day
because it felt like coming back and
doing the same thing over and over again
he revealed on the armchair expert
podcast that prisoner of azkaban was
actually the very last harry potter film
he ever watched and he's never continued
past that point daniel has also admitted
to having some issues with anxiety and
getting used to fame but he doesn't
regret his experience everyone always
expects me to not want to talk about it
or anything but like i you know i i
really don't mind as for emma she almost
did a very hermione-like thing and quit
when she was 16 to focus on her
education
during the first few movies the cast had
to do their homework on set between
takes and even at their hogwarts desks
but for the third movie the director
decided to merge their homework and
character study together there's a
famous story about quran assigning the
trio to each complete an essay about
their character of course emma did the
most by writing an amazing paper while
daniel did the bare minimum and rupert
didn't finish his at all so please i've
done it i've done it i've done it so i
have my the next name that comes in with
all 16 pages of hers being in school
also made their schedules pretty crazy
each day when filming was done they had
to go to tutoring everybody go off to
lovely school
this whomping willow scene was fun to
film and maybe just a bit dangerous emma
hopped on a fake branch to be swung
around but most of the close-up shots of
the duo escaping were accomplished by
having the camera act as a branch itself
it was a fun high-speed scene to film
but all expertly choreographed lupin
transforming into a werewolf in the
movie is impressive sure but it's even
more impressive watching him transform
behind the scenes there were a lot of
prosthetics involved watching yourself
become unrecognizable
was uh exciting they filmed half the
scene before putting him in makeup and
then continued as he was turning they
also had to create this very convincing
werewolf suit we're in the shrieking
shack
aren't we for scenes in the shrieking
shack the crew didn't just rely on cgi
instead they built an actual moving
frame so that it would seem like the
shack was swaying and creaking while the
actors were inside but it was also a lot
safer than filming in a real abandoned
building welcome to the night bus
emergency transport for the stranded
witch or wizard did you know that the
night bus is actually a real bus and
they really drove it around london check
out these quick turns and all the
swaying that would definitely make
passengers a little queasy a
double-decker bus didn't cut it so
instead they took a normal bus and cut
it in half lifted it then added a middle
section and drove it around the city
here you can see the interior scenes
being filmed on a soundstage using a
hydraulic moving platform
peter pettigrew is a sinister villain
sure he might not be the brightest or
the most terrifying but he did put
voldemort's plans into action however
it's not nearly as easy to take him
seriously behind the scenes especially
when sirius tries to get his revenge on
a fake rat but we gotta say the actual
rat actor who plays scabbers that's
pretty cute
you're alive prisoner of azkaban
actually gave a lot of animal actors
their big breaks especially these
surprisingly well-behaved crows and bats
they were trained by the film's animal
trainer gary garrow but it was
definitely difficult to get them go
where they needed to at all times and
for the young actors to get used to all
the fluttering around their heads while
they were trying to remember their lines
another interesting fact crookshanks
whose real name is crackerjack by the
way has such nice fur that they had to
add these clumps to it before filming
have some jelly and put it on his eyes
to make them look weepy so he's not so
handsome what about the cast that almost
was hogwarts almost had a different
headmaster with both of these white
wizards sir ian mckellen and sir
christopher lee being considered to play
dumbledore in the third film but it was
richard harris who passed away after
playing dumbledore in the first two
films who ultimately had the final say
he wasn't a big fan of mckellen's so the
actor decided out of respect not to take
the role christopher lee was focusing
more on playing villains at the time so
he passed too instead we got michael
gambon who brought the perfect amount of
wisdom and charisma to scenes like these
and he had a good time doing it
happiness can be found
even in the
darkest of times
prisoner of azkaban was filmed on
location in scotland where it rained for
28 days straight sets were constantly
being washed out the actors had to be
followed around with umbrellas and they
even had to use helicopters like this
one to fly in gravel to fill in areas
that had been wiped away by all the
water but one perk to all that rain was
that it created a constantly gloomy and
gray tone which ended up being perfect
for the movie the yule ball
is first and foremost a dance
you might think that battles monsters
and magic spells would have been the
biggest challenges behind making harry
potter but one unexpected scene proved
to be the scariest of all the yule ball
i think i take the dragon right now
that's right by the time the goblet of
fire rolled around the cast and crew
were already total pros at filming those
big complicated action scenes but
dancing dressing up in romance well that
was a whole other story
you'd think that having to pretend to
cast spells fight enormous dragons and
other magical creatures and survive
countless near-death experiences would
be the toughest parts of acting in harry
potter movies but it turns out that
there was one thing that terrified the
actors more than any threatening
obstacles they had ever faced before and
that was what
dancing while they all knew it was
coming when it came to having to learn
to not only dance but ballroom dance
during the yule ball not a single one of
the young actors were looking forward to
it well that's not totally true
according to emma watson there was a big
difference between the girls and boys
the girls were all pretty excited to
give it a try but the boys on the other
hand wanted nothing to do with it the
girls are so eager and the guy is just
not there not wanting to do it at all
and we don't really blame them not only
did they have to ballroom dance for the
first time in their lives they had to do
it in front of hundreds of other kids
and an entire crew
safe to say they were terrified i think
the kids were all quite scared of having
to dance formally but no one had it
quite as tough as rupert who if you
remember in the movie had to take a
dance lesson in front of everyone with
professor mcgonagall herself maggie
smith apparently he felt just as awkward
about it as ron did because when he sat
back down next to oliver and james
phelps who played fred and george he
muttered to them not to say a word about
what had just happened so of course they
had to poke fun at him and it doesn't
seem like it was all that easy for
maggie either was pretty strenuous but
don't worry they weren't just thrown in
front of the camera and told to waltz
perfectly they actually had three weeks
of full-time dance training before they
started to film the yule ball scenes
working with professional ballroom dance
teachers and choreographers definitely
helped them get the steps down but that
doesn't mean they all turned into mini
zac efrons prancing around with all the
confidence in the world
oh no
many of the actors still would have
passed on the dancing entirely if they
were given the chance matthew lewis who
plays the notoriously awkward neville
longbottom definitely didn't relish the
whole experience of learning the
complicated ballroom steps one bit
luckily for tom felton he knew that he
wasn't the only one out there who was
feeling a little foolish and that
everyone around him was feeling just as
silly as he was so it wasn't all bad
while everyone else was getting the hang
of it with weeks of group training poor
daniel was so busy filming other scenes
that he was actually only given four
days to catch up and learn the moves
before they were set to film
and not only does he have to dance he
has to dance in front of the entire
school with the other champions so the
pressure was really on for the young
actors first ever dance scene
luckily harry was never supposed to be
the best dancer in the world so all of
his adorable missteps and less than
smooth moves were totally perfect for
the character at that moment who was
also completely terrified and in way
over his head finally they did manage to
finish all of the formal dance moments
and could move on to the more fun weird
sisters concert after all of the stress
and tension of making sure that every
walt step was perfect the whole cast was
finally allowed to really let loose and
mosh for the first time ever at hogwarts
and yet even that sounds a lot easier
than it actually is when you're a
hundred teenagers in wizard robes trying
to forget about the giant cameras
circling around you but they managed to
totally pull it off and give the scene
the burst of energy that it needed
one of the things we love about the
harry potter movies is that we got to
watch the characters really grow up over
the course of eight movies and that goes
for the actors too which is really what
set the goblet of fire apart from all
the other movies that had come before
for the first time the actors and the
characters were teenagers and that
brought on a ton of changes which became
very obvious when it came time to film
the yule ball the producers and all the
other older actors noticed such a
difference in the way the young cast
behaved around one another and just how
awkward things were starting to get
which they thought was totally perfect
for the energy of the entire movie and
especially the formal dancing
celebrating the tri-wizard tournament
when you watch the scene and see how
awkward it is for the boys and girls to
interact once they're all dressed up
most of what you see is totally real
when it came to asking cho chang out to
the dance daniel radcliffe didn't have
to work hard to tap into how
uncomfortable it can be to ask out your
crush and rupert grint actually thought
the acting part was a whole lot easier
than having to ask someone out for real
in real life it's pretty scary
there is really no way for us to talk
about the yule ball without talking
about the awesome costumes that made the
whole thing come to life the costume
designer knew that fans expectations
were going to be really high for this
moment so she and her team worked hard
to bring a high level of fantasy to the
big screen and there is no doubt that
the entire cast were really excited to
get to change out of their school robes
and into their finest dress robes for a
night well
almost the entire cast
while everyone else got to dress up and
look their best we all know what
happened to ron mom sent me a dress
and it's safe to say that rupert grint
wasn't all that happy about it either
but there was one reveal that did take
everyone's breath away in a good way
when hermione first stepped out in her
pink gown a lot of fans were a bit
disappointed that it wasn't the blue
they had imagined from reading the book
but what they didn't know is how many
different versions of the dress were
designed before finally settling on the
light pink one that really suited emma
watson's version of hermione the best
it wasn't all glitz and glamour however
as emma tripped on her long skirt and
almost fell down the stairs on her first
take i was absolutely terrified once
they were all in costume and ready to go
the actors were brought into the
famously breathtaking great hall and for
a handful of the actors the set really
did take their breath away the crew had
really built huge crystal icicles that
hung from the magic ceiling brought in
christmas trees that stood multiple
stories high and added a ton of
incredibly ornate decorations on all of
the walls and tables transforming the
already impressive great hall into the
ice palace that everyone who read the
book had imagined of course some things
in the wizarding world couldn't be done
for real so with the help of a little
bit of cgi magic the great hall was
really brought to life for the final
film animators added gently falling snow
that never quite reached the ground a
night sky full of glittering stars above
the dance floor and torches glowing
warmly along the halls in order to truly
capture just how enchanting the ewo ball
would have been
all of the hard work that went into the
making of the yule ball from the dancing
to the costumes to the amazing set that
was made even more beautiful through cgi
came together to create something that
really was
magic after all of that they must have
been thrilled to go back to fighting
dragons in the dark lord you know the
easy stuff floor is um it's like a
special material so i mean people have
to wear these sort of
blue shoe covers over a decade later
we're still discovering behind the
scenes secrets from the harry potter
franchise today we're covering all the
must-know trivia from harry potter in
the order of the phoenix how did the
actors cause chaos on a construction set
why did daniel radcliffe's scream have
to be silent
so that's your
bit of knowledge for today
working on a movie in the harry potter
franchise means a lot of time on set
which also means a lot of time to fill
with activities and shenanigans
when shooting harry potter in the order
of the phoenix the cast had a variety of
activities to keep them busy when they
weren't learning potions and battling
the dark lord when they weren't playing
quidditch the young wizards were outside
playing another sport cricket that's
right here we can see matthew lewis and
alfred enoch sharpening up their cricket
skills or trying to at least
we wonder how often they took homework
breaks
some in for
one of the tutors which i haven't done
daniel radcliffe and gary oldman didn't
just bond on screen they spent quality
time together off-screen as well
how many films have you done
forty-something there must be now as for
nymphadora tonks actress natalia tenna
music was more her style here she is in
her trailer playing some of her own
original songs evidently the cast is
full of surprise talents it wasn't all
fun and games though remember that many
of the actors were still in school and
regularly needed to do homework the team
did take a planned nine-week break from
filming for daniel radcliffe and emma
watson the two actors had to do some
major school exams i have worked
hard every single day that i was at that
school while the actors were working
they got to learn some new skills in the
wizarding world with wand choreography
since the fifth film in the series
incorporated a lot of high level wand
work paul harris a dance choreographer
was brought in to teach the actors how
best to work with the styles and
techniques to really bring their
wizarding to life
they had five basic moves to use with
every character adding their own special
touches to each according to their
personality this work was definitely
intense so much so that many of the
actors actually wound up breaking their
wands resulting in them using rubber
ones instead which were more durable
than the wood breaking the most ones
throughout the films i think i think is
about 10. at the time of this film the
record holder for the most wands broken
was devin murray who'd already gone
through 10 different wands wands can be
very dangerous business and no one would
know that better than matthew lewis who
suffered a perforated eardrum after
helena bonham carter accidentally
stabbed his ear with a wand speaking of
bonham carter the actress happened to
have some enhancements for the movie
she'd had chicken fillet inserts to put
inside her bra while shooting
what's this rubbish what's this rubbish
he says this could sort of be considered
character work the weasley twins were
always practicing to up their trickery
game the actors were notorious for
playing little pranks on set but one
really blew them all away and actually
got the twins and their little sister
into a bit of trouble there was a big
construction site across from a studio
the movie was shooting in and the
weasley siblings weaseled their way onto
the site's walkie talkie channel there
were plenty of devices around the set so
the actors thought it would be fun to
tell the construction workers that they
could go home and it probably was
until the gaffer caught them and gave
them a very good talking to and say
mischief managed otherwise anyone can
read it there were some more laughs that
happened on set that weren't trick
related those came around with the
kissing scenes remember how the trio
giggled throughout talking about harry
kissing cho
i'm sure harry's kissing was more than
satisfactory
all that was real the actors kept
cracking up and it was just so enjoyable
that the team kept the cameras rolling
and it made the final edit it's no
surprise considering there was quite a
build up katie liang was pretty nervous
about the kiss and really prepared
herself mentally beforehand but then
when the planned shoot date came the
kiss had to wait because radcliffe wound
up being sick daniel is a very good
kisser when it came to stunts rupert
grint had a pretty strange experience
when shooting the scene where hermione
throws ron across a room usually there
would just be a harness but to really
help show the stunt realistically grint
was strapped to a much larger man who
was moving up and down a ladder
it is pretty hard to think of harry
potter without emma watson ruper grint
and daniel radcliffe at the center of
the movies but the fact is order of the
phoenix was almost watson's last film
with the franchise the actress had
seriously considered leaving the role so
she could concentrate on other pursuits
after taking some time to weigh the pros
and cons watson felt that it would have
been way too strange to watch any other
actress play the role that she'd grown
up doing so she made the choice to stay
until the end we are definitely glad she
did i definitely made the right decision
another gem from the wizarding world is
luna lovegood it was the rule of a
lifetime for the actress since she'd
actually been a fan of the series since
she was eight years old and her favorite
character was
you guessed it
luna
well if i were you know who
i'd want you to feel cut off from
everyone else she got to bring a bit
more of herself to the role as well the
multi-talented actress actually made the
radish earrings that we see her wearing
building the incredible settings we see
throughout the fifth film is extensive
and always impressive sometimes it could
even be pretty dangerous the ministry of
magic building took 22 weeks to build
and was only on screen for about 10
minutes total the set was of course
rigged up to be exploded meaning if the
cast had their cell phones on set they
could have accidentally triggered it and
blown the set up there were also some
buildings that were just too expensive
to be in the movie
sirius black's london residence grimmeld
place was built by the film team since
the building they needed to shoot in
would have been too expensive it says a
lot considering the fact that
constructing a set like this isn't that
cheap either
speaking of the black family this
gorgeous family tree has the names of
over 70 different members of the black
family the jk rowling created for the
movie i've never used the visitors
entrance before
it should be fun the ministry of magic
was brought to life with two very
different techniques painted cardboard
and full on cgi while pretty well every
setting in the movies is epic the
department of mysteries where this wild
battle takes place was actually the very
first shot in the movies to be entirely
created with cgi we don't blame them
considering how major that cleanup would
have been
get back to the door
we're a bit surprised the team didn't
choose to use cgi for the 30 000
individual tiles that were added to the
ministry set by hand the so-called tiles
were actually made out of cardboard
covered in very thick paint as real
tiles would have been far too expensive
the ingenuity of the team doesn't stop
there though how does maddie moody
manage to ride a broomstick with a
prosthetic leg especially customized
broom instead of the stirrups the other
actors used actor brendan gleason wrote
a broom that had posts at the front for
his legs and a seat for him to sit on
stay in formation everyone don't break
ranks one of our absolute favorite
references in the whole movie has to be
harry's nod to a beloved character remus
lupin
you know the very first time i saw you
harry i recognized you immediately
if harry's teaching fashion is familiar
then it's probably because it's very
closely modeled after the closed
professor lupine war during harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban radcliffe
brought the idea to his producers
because he thought it would be a good
way to pay respect to the professor he
looked up to so much people like me uh
well let's just say that i'm used to it
right now
the creative choices in this film really
made it a standout one in particular
still manages to move us every time we
see it harry's scream after sirius black
passes away
the choice to make the heartbreaking
moment silent was reportedly because the
actual scream recorded was so painful
that it made emma watson and helena
bonham carter actually cry we can't even
imagine watching and hearing the scene
in person the original audio has still
never been released publicly as for this
terrifying moment the wacky eye color
change harry has is courtesy of cgi as
opposed to contact since of course
radcliffe wasn't able to wear contacts
as with all the films they aren't
entirely consistent with what's written
in the novels one of the more notable
changes in this movie was of course the
purple hair tonks has instead of the
signature pink she's described as having
in the novel
the team felt pink was too associated
with dolores umbridge and didn't want
there to be any connections between the
two characters the purple hairdo took
about 30 minutes to prepare every single
day with part of her real hair that had
been dyed as well as a purple lace wig
that she had on another change was
creature being included in the movie
while his role isn't huge it was
important enough to add to the script
after jk rowling insisted he be included
in order for other scenes that needed to
happen in future to make sense all his
scenes were actually added after the
principal shooting then of course how
could we forget nigel
well if you've only read the books then
you absolutely wouldn't know who nigel
is since he was a character created just
for the movie without any mention in the
book series
as for the characters that were in the
novels the bellatrix lestrange we got in
the movies was almost played by another
actress pretty close to home helen
mccrory was originally set to play
bellatrix but after learning she was
pregnant the role went to helena bonham
carter luckily we did get to meet her
later on as narcissa malfoy both roles
are pretty impeccably cast in the end
protect him from harm
want the inside scoop on harry potter
and the half blood prince we've got you
covered we all know and love the harry
potter series with the half blood prince
being one of the classics but did you
know about all the magic and effort put
into the behind-the-scenes production
that made the movie come to life one's
ready broomstick's ready and away we go
right from the get-go it seems like
harry potter and the half-blood prince
is
full of special and practical effects
which make the film stand out as the
production team has led on this harry
potter film has about the same amount of
special effects as any of the other
films these special effects stand apart
from the other films though and how they
are integrated into the scenes the use
of cgi and other effects is much more
blended into the real world acting and
settings that the film uses with
explosive devices in all the various
different parts of the bathroom so as
soon as you just spell someone load the
behind the scenes of these effects makes
the film all the more interesting to
watch in its final form it's crazy to
think about all the possibilities that
arise when a simple green screen is
involved green screens were used
throughout this film to create the cgi
effects that blow viewers away for the
quidditch scenes in the film the use of
blue screens was truly imperative to
creating the right shots in reality
actors were simply seated on bicycle
seats and fitted with a harness on
something that resembled a broomstick
while placed in front of a blue screen
all the magic of the quidditch game and
the intense background and action were
mostly added in digitally it's quite
tricky for me because there's nothing to
react to one really interesting and
unique iteration of the green screen is
in the magical bookshelf scene of the
half-blood prince in this
behind-the-scenes look we can see green
hands extending from the bookshelves
that hermione is standing in front of in
the end these hands would be digitally
erased leaving behind the effect of
books magically being placed back in
their rightful spots within the library
in the burrow burn scene we can see a
green well blue screen extending in the
background of the shot this blue screen
was used to enhance the locational
setting where the scene was actually
taking place in the burrow burn scene
where in the weasley family home is
attacked by bellatrix lestrange special
and practical effects were used to set
the stage for the gruesome attack on the
family home the special effects team
used real fire to simulate the attack
with a ring of fire spreading around the
set at almost 420 feet long special
effects specialist john richardson
claimed that the ring of fire was
definitely a learning process as the
crew had to learn and re-learn what ways
to make the fire work best on the set
you're arrogant
the character if you can call it that of
aragog was also a huge component of the
practical effects that made the film
truly stand out the practical effects
team needed to make a completely new
giant spider for this film says makeup
and creature effects designer nick
dudman he's essentially it's the same
character and he looks essentially the
same although we've upgraded him a
little
says dudman in the creation of this
spidery creature the special effects
team chose a material to produce the
spider that was translucent to try to
mimic what a real dead bug might look
like it took a team of over a dozen
people to work on aragog including tasks
like filling the mold to airbrushing
final details in fact it took a team of
six to seven people just to work on
placing the spider hairs on the giant
creature which took weeks on end the
amount of effort that went into creating
this giant spider really paid off when
paired with the acting scene in the film
seriously misunderstood creatures
spiders are
the eyes i reckon they unnerve some folk
as nick dudman states very often even
just an inanimate object like that can
have a you know a little emotive moment
which is nice bringing the cave scene to
magical life was a hugely important step
in the process of making the half-blood
prince the production team did a lot of
research on caves looking into different
rock formations to use leading them to
the crystal cave idea they visited a
quartz crystal cave in switzerland and a
salt cave in germany to find inspiration
they also took inspiration from the
cliffs of moher in ireland for the
iconic cave scene the set itself was too
large of a scale to fully build so the
team took to using cgi to animate the
setting having gained confidence from
their first all cg scene in harry potter
five you should have let me sir oh no
harry
your blood's much more precious than
mine
as the film opens the viewers watch as
death eaters make their way through both
the wizarding world and the muggle world
tearing apart a pedestrian bridge as
they fly through the sky it's
interesting to take an exclusive look
behind the scenes of the making of this
scene as a lot more went into it than
one might initially expect what you
might not have figured out about the
scene is the insane amount of effort
that went into getting those soaring
shots through the british skies it took
the use of one helicopter and one
stabilized camera to get the perfect
shot and then obviously quite a bit of
cgi magic to place the death eaters
within the scene
[Music]
the acting in all the harry potter films
worked to set these mainly child
star-studded films apart from the rest
it's no surprise that the acting
performances from stars like emma watson
daniel radcliffe and rupert grint also
shine through in harry potter and the
half-blood prince but what were their
experiences like behind the scenes and
on set let's dive in
can't you trust me let's start off with
the acting involved in harry and jenny's
love story the blossoming of harry and
jenny's romance takes a central role in
the half-blood prince with the first
kiss shared between the two counting as
a pivotal scene in the film as the
actors behind the kiss dished it wasn't
as smooth and romantic in real life as
it seemed in the film when everyone
comes in and have a look at the scene
you know lighting or the crew it's a bit
embarrassing but i think after a while
you just gotta accept it daniel
radcliffe revealed that the kiss scene
was a bit awkward for him since he knew
actress bonnie wright who plays ginny
since she was just a child of about 10
years old so it's a bit weird doing all
that but it's it's fine this scene was
the very first one that bonnie actually
shot on set making the tension almost
palpable to the young actress she stated
that i think the first time is always
the worst but after that it's just like
any other scene that you're filming so
it was actually easier than i realized
harry was also involved in some
behind-the-scenes goofing with co-star
emma watson in the magical library scene
watson hit radcliffe over the head so
hard by accident he even said you can
really hear the crunch of paper on bone
you're laughing because you hit me so
hard aren't you okay similarly lavender
and ron's kiss scene was also filled
with a bit of tension and awkwardness
it's just such a weird sort of thing but
everyone watching you and it's just just
didn't feel very this kiss scene was at
a whole new level of weird in comparison
to harry and jenny's because it took
place in front of dozens of extras
daniel radcliffe in particular was
extremely excited about this kiss scene
making a point to be present off camera
while the smooch took place on screen i
don't think rupa had done a kissing
scene and that was entirely new
territory for him talk about friends
cheering each other on jessie cave who
plays lavender revealed that it was
actually the most awkward to film the
rehearsal scene when it was just her
rupert and the director because that was
much more intimate of a kiss than the
one in front of the cast was she claimed
that the awkwardness of the kiss was not
really a big deal to her but her true
fear when kissing rupert i was more
concerned anyway about honestly chipping
a tooth i really was worried another
interesting yet much more serious note
about the acting during the half-blood
prince was maggie smith's health during
filming the actress who famously plays
professor mcgonagall in the series was
actually undergoing breast cancer
treatment during the time of filming she
was working on set while undergoing
chemotherapy at the same time which was
no small feat as the actress said she
was in pain constantly and also feeling
deathly sick smith tried to make light
of the situation and is even quoted
saying i was hairless i had no problem
getting the wig on i was like a boiled
egg
it's clear that the special effects and
the actors both work to make this film
truly special but what about the rest of
the production team that also made the
magic of the half-blood prince come to
life it's clear that the production
decisions from the screenwriters to the
director worked to make this chapter of
the harry potter series truly special
the director of harry potter and the
half-blood prince david yates truly
shared a unique bond with the actors on
set making their relationship as well as
his professional choices inherently
important to the production of hp6 not
just for me as a storyteller but also
with the actors i wanted to see them
play more comedy some of his decisions
were a bit controversial despite his
general popularity among the actors on
set it's been revealed that screenwriter
steve cloves actually argued back and
forth with yates over whether or not
they should include more pensive memory
scenes showing voldemort's background in
the movie yates ended up actually
vetoing the writers wishes opting for
less of the voldemort flashbacks to be
included in the film
who are you
well i'm like you tom
i'm different
prove it film editor mark day was also a
big player in the creation of the
half-blood prince and his decisions also
influenced the way the film came out for
sure with a total of five editors for
the harry potter series in total mark
day has stuck around to edit two of them
in total day worked for 14 months
editing the film making decisions when
to cut to different shots within a scene
and being responsible for more than 1
700 edits within the film editing is
very subjective and so what you may
think is a good cut i may not not only
do the director and editors have big
roles in the production process but so
do lesser acknowledge team members like
stunt specialists they're in charge of
all the quidditch acrobatics that the
actors have to perform including some of
these impressive and not so impressive
saves made by the keeper ron weasley
behind the scenes and we can't forget
the important makeup artists like amanda
knight who make all the magic of the
story really come to life before our
eyes as we can see here amanda
transforms actress emma watson by giving
her the dark mark with a temporary
tattoo i'd have to say it would be a
wonderful way to travel in a sidecar as
the iconic harry potter film franchise
was closing in on its climax the set
provided plenty of pulse racing stunts
and heartfelt send-offs today we're
covering the must-know moments from the
deathly hallows part one how did they
pull off the seven harry's scene what
was the final day on set like i was so
upset on the last day i really was
everyone was
much of the deathly hallows part 1 takes
place in the real world or the muggle
world for you wizards out there and in
order to pull that off the production
found itself filming all over the uk and
having the cast perform in these very
real environments but some sequences
were a little too dangerous for actors
to do themselves that was the case for
harry's dangerous ride with hagrid to
the weasley house while daniel radcliffe
was in the sidecar for a shot or two the
rest of the time it was his stunt double
mark maylie i'm yet to travel more than
about three meters in it but those three
meetings were some of the funnest i've
ever had seven identical motorbikes were
built for different stunts in the scene
including for flying flipping upside
down crashing into the water for the
landing and traveling as fast as 40
miles per hour in the actual liverpool
queensbury tunnel even though radcliffe
missed out on these stunts first hand he
found the bright side in being
represented by maylie
and also a plus side of having mark um w
is his legendary for having a very very
nice bump the location for the set of
godric's hollow was dictated largely by
an actual cedar tree production designer
stewart craig found the tree in the
garden at the legendary pinewood studios
and built the tiny town with it in mind
using it as the centerpiece of the
graveyard the crew also did quite a
number on resident befilda bagshot's
creepy home lining the rooms with dusty
boxes clothes and even making books that
the character had written herself inside
bethilda bagshot's home daniel radcliffe
did his own stunts when taking on
voldemort's pet snake nagini to give
daniel the experience of being attacked
by cgi nagini the stunt coordinator greg
powell used a pole with a boxing glove
tied to the end to poke and push
radcliffe we've had some crazy things
fill in for whatever the creature's
supposed to be but on one take powell
went a little overboard and ended up
giving radcliffe a fat lip when the
chair he was using as a shield hit him
in the face radcliffe however took the
minor injury in stride so i had a fat
lip for about a day but it's it's it's
really calmed down so i'm feeling pretty
good because i've got a photo on sunday
when it comes to filming in real world
locations piccadilly circus in london is
apparently a pretty big deal do you have
to watch the movie where we shut down
piccadilly circle for the first time in
32 years radcliffe rupert grint and emma
watson walked through the world famous
site surrounded by an insane 500 extras
the all-night cafe where the trio does
battle with voldemort loyalists has a
real world easter egg of its own the
crew put up a poster of equus a stage
play daniel radcliffe was starring in at
the time placing the hell selves dobby
and creature in the same space as the
actors required a collaboration of onset
stand-ins actors who voiced the elves
and eventually cgi of the house elves
themselves i'm a dobby
move isn't it
he's he's creature
but i'm better
stand-ins diane gibbons and mindy joe
hall worked with the other actors on set
with their performances used as
references by the vfx team to create the
final sequences with the real dobby and
creature actor simon mcburney and toby
jones ultimately voiced the house elves
with toby jones even coming on set for
dobby's emotional final scene
i want to bury him
properly
without magic
with a crazy 261 shooting days on the
deathly hallows production the cast and
long time friends had to find ways to
keep things fresh on such a long shoot
daniel radcliffe and rupert grint opted
to invent their own game with mini table
tennis paddles hilariously dubbed danger
ball for the second ever but first
outdoors danger ball 2009 champion clips
rupert grint managed to find time to
goof off on set as well grint and his
off-screen twin brothers oliver and
james phelps could usually be found
messing around on segways and sneaking
into the studio at night we've actually
been kind of riding our bikes all
through the set and before filming rapt
rupert the phelps twins and draco malfoy
actor tom felton got a chance to go
golfing together though some were
definitely worse than others it's not a
very good girlfriend actually
things got a lot more competitive during
the chase in the woods scene where ron
harry and hermione are on the run from
death eaters it wasn't long at all
before the trio retreating each take
like a race they're all going to say to
the fastest i am them said emma probably
she's wrong i'm fast it got so
competitive that director david yates
had to remind them that the most
important thing was what was best for
the film and not who was the fastest but
daniel was more than happy to settle it
once and for all at a later date call it
red carpet next premiere we'll do i'll
have a race man make it 100 yards i'll
do it when it came time to do harry and
hermione's steamy kiss ron wasn't
actually there to see his own
horcrux-induced vision the intimate
scene required that both daniel and emma
be topless and covered in silver paint
so in order to make the two as
comfortable as possible everyone who
didn't need to be on set for it wasn't
including rupert grint watson confirmed
the decision saying they did yes it was
a closed set and it was awkward enough
without having tons of people come and
watch
the first of the original cast to rap
for good was fittingly the dursleys this
isn't just goodbye boy is it this is
farewell fiona shaw richard griffiths
and harry melling were the first along
with radcliffe to film for the harry
potter series 10 years prior in the
sorcerer's stone or philosopher's stone
depending on where you are in the world
in the time since the family's
relationship had evolved off-screen as
well with radcliffe and griffiths acting
together in a stage play and melling and
shaw doing the same
while the epilogue from part two was the
final scene it was not the last thing
that was filmed the final day of filming
was done at leaves done studios the same
place where they started on the first
film 10 years before its basic back has
been reserved for me
so
that's what i have to do today after the
final shot which had harry ron and
hermione leaping to escape the ministry
of magic the crew surprised them with a
heartfelt video chronicling the past 200
plus days on the production i've loved
every minute and thank you all very very
much daniel radcliffe really got a
chance to show off his acting chops when
he was tasked with playing seven
versions of harry that were being
impersonated by seven different
characters seven harris this is the most
complicated scene in the world in order
to pull this off radcliffe was coached
by each actor on their character's
mannerisms and movements it was really
fun it's bloody confusing though he
managed to impress not only the actors
but david yates as well dan plays women
really well actually while radcliffe
pulled them all off splendidly he did
take to some quicker than others
specifically emma watson's hermione
harry your eyesight really is awful
often it's the details that really
elevate a film to the next level and the
deathly hallows was no different these
key artistic decisions and contributions
came from not only the crew but even the
talented cast as well magical tents had
been introduced in the goblet of fire
and in the deathly hallows part one they
came back in a big way set decorator
stephanie macmillan and production
designer stuart craig designed a
gorgeous magical tent for the setting of
bill weasley and fleur delacour's
wedding you know they've got the
gorgeous the lights that hover and the
tables look it is definitely a french
influence in stark contrast to the grand
purple wedding tent is the tiny plain
tent harry ron and hermione travel with
for the bulk of the film
[Music]
yeah
i'm still here mcmillan and craig's aim
was to make it look almost identical to
the one in the goblet of fire at least
on the outside it's amazing how much
yeah richness and interest you can get
out of a couple of sheets of canvas
basically actor warwick davis has played
more than one character during his time
on the harry potter films and the one
role that he is probably least
recognizable in is griphook the goblin
chief mold maker led a team of artists
that work together to give davis his
goblin face each piece of the prosthetic
mask had to be carefully placed on one
at a time in a process that took about
four hours to apply and another hour to
remove
[Music]
the prosthetic mask and accompanying
contacts made it so difficult to see
that every goblin actor including davis
required a chaperone to get around the
set
hello
ready for the office
talented actor evanna lynch who
portrayed the peculiar luna lovegood
it's a charm actually
keeps away the nargles was well known
around the production for making
artistic contributions to her character
but those contributions extended to the
set itself when she inspired the design
of the love good house lynch created
drawings of magical beasts in the style
of luna herself which were used as a
reference for the paintings that
ultimately covered every inch of the
lovegood home but evanna lynch made sure
not to ignore her beloved character
inventing the dance luna and her father
perform at bill weasley and fleur
delacour's wedding she's so in touch
with her spirit that she's not really
affected by other people hopefully
someday daniel radcliffe and rupert
grint will make an official rule book
for danger ball so we can all play i
haven't really thought about it because
we've still got a long way to go yet on
this one very messy time for the castle
literally just like hogwarts the harry
potter films are full of secrets and
facts that even the most dedicated fans
aren't aware of the deathly hallows part
2 was an epic finale to the franchise
but behind the scenes it was packed with
major challenges record-breaking moments
and a very emotional cast ready to dive
into this chamber of secrets rupert was
like
i don't know how we're gonna do it and i
was like i've got no idea either
[Music]
since 2001 harry potter had been making
the impossible possible with their
groundbreaking visual effects and
mind-blowing costume and makeup
department so it only made sense that
for their final film they take all those
special effects to another level the
room of requirement scene was so much
more than just a final antic between the
gryffindors and slytherins that hidden
classroom symbolized harry's childhood
at hogwarts a place he'd spent hours and
hours in a room that at the end of the
scene would be completely destroyed to
make the scene even more impactful the
filmmakers filled the set with
memorabilia from the seven previous
films including the knight the golden
trio used in their philosopher's stone
chess game but aside from the props the
rest of the scene was filmed with a
whole lot of rope green screen and
mechanical broomsticks that according to
emma weren't the most comfortable the
mechanical broomsticks worked a lot like
an amusement park ride and to take the
edge off the actors had their bottoms
molded to create a seat they could sit
on even before they said go it's like
grabbing hold of the thing saying don't
let me fall speaking of blasts from the
past another set that had to be
recreated from the first films was
gringotts bank the lestrange vault
break-in took a lot out of the prop
department not only did they have to dig
out and refurbish props from the first
film but had to construct 210 000
different gold trinkets so that they
were able to fill the lestrange vault as
much as possible before bringing in vfx
for the gemino curse while gringotts
took a lot out of the prop department
the battle of hogwarts was on a whole
other level the battle of hogwarts might
just be the most difficult but rewarding
sequence of the entire franchise the
planning of these moments happened two
years before the film even released when
they traded in their physical hogwarts
replica for a digital one the digital
hogwarts was the only way they'd be able
to make the battle as realistic as
possible with a practical hogwarts we
would have shot it last summer and been
so tied down instead as david yates
finds the flow and structure we are able
to handle new concepts and ideas gives
me tremendous freedom to move the camera
in and around the place when it's being
destroyed that was quite useful things
like the magic shield were also
incorporated into the digital hogwarts
afterward however they still did need to
create the rubble of hogwarts apart from
the digital aspects but the scene
required a lot of running and chaos
meaning the filmmakers needed to make
sure no one got hurt in the process
because of this every piece of rubble
was made out of a phone-like material
for even more safety during voldemort
and harry's final battle ray feinz and
daniel radcliffe were surrounded by mats
that they would edit out later even then
dan still needed his stunt double to
jump in for certain parts that was the
scariest part it was scary the
tumultuous finale was so chaotic that
some of the actors didn't even film
their scenes together specifically the
moment when harry is speaking to helena
ravenclaw about the lost diadem you do
know
where he hit it
actress kelly macdonald filmed her part
separately in the studio in front of a
screen because daniel was not available
that day he filmed his part at another
time and the two clips were seamlessly
added together what if we told you that
robbie coltrane wasn't the only one
portraying hagrid in fact during the
battle of hogwarts robbie only played
hagrid when they needed shots of his
face for body shots they'd use a stunt
double who was able to balance pounds of
padding while walking on stilts and
carrying a limp harry potter
and the many things i like about him
do you know what i mean
we've discussed how epic of a job the
prop department did on this film but
let's take a look and highlight some of
the best work from the makeup department
at least the best according to daniel
radcliffe they were tasked with making
kieran hines as aberforth look like
michael gambon as dumbledore the before
and after of kieran is mind-boggling the
process included a prosthetic forehead
eye bags and a nose piece not only did
he look eerily like his on-screen
brother but he was able to pull off the
character seamlessly
the fineness of the work they do it's
really special
the battle of hogwarts wasn't just
chaotic for the filmmakers but for the
actors as well it took months to film
and because of how complex it was the
cast didn't get the fairy tale harry
potter rap day they had been expecting
while the battle of hogwarts was the
last scene for many of the cast they
would all rap sporadically each day
after calling cut the names of cast
members who were rapping that day were
read off of a list that is alan and
david doulas last day on harry potter
and tom felton said there wasn't even
time to get emotional because of how
bizarre it was even actor mark williams
called rapping pretty underwhelming
in a state of slightly heightened
consciousness
because any minute now you're going to
have to go poor rupert didn't even get
to be in the final cast and crew picture
because he wasn't on set that day
instead they included a cardboard cutout
of him but for rupert it wasn't the
final cut that made him the most
emotional it was cleaning out the
dressing room he'd spent the last decade
in that did it for him he said he found
toys in the room from when he started
the harry potter journey at just 11
years old and it made him realize that
saying goodbye to potter also meant
saying goodbye to his childhood it's
kind of been my life every day every
hour so it's what it's all been about he
wasn't the only one thinking that way
either matthew lewis also had plenty of
moments of reflection on how much he'd
grown alongside neville and how much he
cherished each moment except for the fat
suits he had to wear and they said okay
we're gonna have to do something about
this and that's when they came up with
the idea of the fat soup i had to wear
for several years
in between farewell speeches and tears
daniel emma and rupert still managed to
exchange some heartwarming rap gifts
emma bought the boys inscribed personal
journals dan got them framed pictures of
memorable moments they had filming and
rupert he got them trumpets engraved
trumpets even he doesn't know why he
decided to go down the musical
instrument route rupa gave me a trumpet
which he had self-engraved i don't play
the trumpet speaking of memorable
moments emma watson shared what her most
memorable scene was while filming
deathly hallows part two and it wasn't
the most pleasant experience emma watson
says the worst scene in the entire film
to shoot was when they get dropped into
a lake by the dragon they're flying on
it was so cold that rupert thought that
his heart stopped they weren't allowed
to wear any clothes underneath because
the next scene required them to change
she just couldn't wait for this scene to
be over
although the tone was oftentimes
emotional on set rae finds made sure to
keep everyone on their toes how did he
do that with improv of course like
always voldemort's final speech to the
students of hogwarts and his death
eaters was eerie and nothing short of
epic from this day forth
you put your faith
in me but it turns out that was all rafe
each take he would divert from the
script and improvise his speech in order
to keep the rest of the cast alert and
on their toes jason isaacs called his
performance utterly terrifying if you
thought the hug was super awkward
between voldemort and draco there's a
reason why yes it's because voldemort is
literally the most awkward being in the
harry potter universe but it was also
because rafe completely improvised it it
caught tom off guard which garnered an
even better response from tom for helena
bonham carter and emma watson though
their scene was anything but improvised
the two actresses became extremely close
on set of this film because of the fact
they'd have to play one another in
gringotts emma took this very seriously
she wrote notes on hermione for helena
that she could always have on her phone
and even acted out the scene for her
before it was time for her take you have
to call me emma
although this film was packed with the
most talented actors and crew members in
the uk it didn't come without its
challenges the deathly hallows part 2
had the largest cast in the franchise
this was mainly because of the battle of
hogwarts scenes where there were more
than 400 actors on set at once this led
to a lot of chaos each of those 400
actors needed a custom costume and a
unique wand each we know each day that
each student gets the same one they had
the day before the gringotts goblins may
have been the most challenging part of
filming each actor was wearing heavy
duty prosthetics that were customized to
their face and took eight months to
prepare they're so detailed that each
individual strand of hair was sewed on
by hand the prosthetics were so advanced
that they had to fly in 150 of the most
skilled makeup artists around the globe
to help them pull this off to make
matters worse the prosthetics made it
difficult for the actors to see and they
would need to have a leader guide them
around the set each day the end result
though was nothing short of perfection
painstaking process of
having their faces cast in plaster while
this film had the biggest cast the
franchise had ever seen some people may
be wondering why crab draco's right hand
man was missing from the final movie
especially because in the novel he's the
one who was meant to conjure the fiend
fire that destroyed the ravenclaw diadem
horcrux and almost destroyed himself
harry and draco however his actor jamie
whalett got in trouble with the law for
illegal substances and was removed from
the franchise instead they replaced his
character with blaze zambini another
slytherin harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2 wrapped up a 10-year
franchise that was part of so many
people's lives without the efforts from
the cast and crew behind the scenes
including the bonds created between the
cast putting together such an amazing
conclusion wouldn't have been possible
even despite the challenges they faced
what behind the scenes fact did you find
the most interesting let us know below
thanks for watching